right so when you study generational
wealth and you go to Rothschild you go
to Rockefellers you go to Vanderbilts
you go to Medici family all of these
guys you will see Vanderbilts were so
flipping wealthy but his living trust
sucked yeah I think he had like 11 kids
within one generation or two boom all
the money was gone medicis kept it in
the family I think Seven Generations
Rockefellers kept in the family three
generations I believe I believe the way
we create the laws we can say let's not
vote bad people in here but okay can you
be a great parent and have one of your
kids that meets a teacher at UC Berkeley
and flips them and all of a sudden they
become a person that cannot agree with
anything you're saying in your evil
parent and all this other stuff and if
you give that guy the money he's going
to go give the money to so all I'm
saying is we can't control evil people
we can't control people that get
influenced to do dumb things okay we
cannot control it even great parents
could have bad kids